du match des idées confrontation de
points de vue ce soir entre aurore
laluque et yves derai
on va revenir sur le feuilleton darmanin
pulvar et sur la stratégie potentiel
qu'il y a eu derrière après l'épisode
plainte contre plein de celui de la
rencontre une rencontre qui a priori se
tiendra la semaine prochaine d'après
gérald darmanin qui l'a dit au sénat
tout à l'heure mais ils rencontrent pour
quoi faire
quels enseignements tirer de cette
séquence on va tenter de répondre à
cette question après les premiers
éléments d'analysé ils sont signés
agathe tournon en menaçant audrey pulvar
gérald darmanin s'érige une nouvelle
fois en fervent défenseur des forces de
l'ordre un soutien qui illustre une
volonté politique la stratégie qui
aujourd'hui celle d'emmanuel macron et
que porte gérardin manin qui est une
triangulation à droite et bien la
volonté d'opposer et de capitaliser
justement sur le soutien aux forces de
l'ordre et quelque chose qui est assez
porteur et même si cette judiciarisation
du débat est récusée au sein même de la
majorité
à quelques semaines des élections
régionales et départementales
la prise de position du ministre de
l'intérieur pourrait bénéficier au
président de la république de remettre
en selle audrey pulvar est quelque chose
qui est si avant pensez toujours comme
je le disais dans la perspective de 2022
parce que quel que soit le coup de main
qui va donner à audrey poule à elle
n'arrivera pas en tête au premier tour
et elle n'a aucune chance de remporter
la région toutefois si elle pouvait
solidariser à gauche
cet électorat est bien tout ça est très
favorable non pas à la république en
marche mais à la stratégie 2022
d'emmanuel marque gérald darmanin et
audrey pulvar devrait se rencontrer
prochainement pour le moment aucune
plainte n'a été déposée avec nous pour
le match des idées ce soir aurore la
lutte bienvenue vous êtes économiste
eurodéputés place publique et auteur de
ce livre reconquête au nom de l'intérêt
générale face à vous il devrait bien
venu vous êtes journaliste et
éditorialiste politique rédacteur en
chef chez ford france je vouvoyais
réagir pendant pendant le sujet on peut
pas imaginer qu'il ait fait ça sans
qu'il y ait un sens je parle de gérald
darmanin qui est envisagé cette plainte
contre audrey pulvar il n'y a pas de
stratégie derrière vous
ah non j'ai pas dit il est passé à tj
non là la stratégie par rapport aux
régionales je crois pas deux secondes
maintenant il ya une stratégie de gérald
darmanin qu'elle est là bas d'abord
d'essayer de montrer dans un premier
temps aux policiers qu'il était
solidaire de il a déjà montré en avant
la manifestation l'a donc va jusqu'à
porter plainte contre audrey pulvar pour
les défendre d'une certaine manière
puisqu'elle a critiqué de l'acteur avait
pas déposer la plante est pas sûr qu il
aille ou fait en allemand d'autant que
sa collègue barbara pont pie par exemple
ce matin semblait dire quand même que
dans une démocratie la liberté
d'expression c'est ça existe et que
c'est pas la manière de faire la
politique quoi donc
et maintenant il ya une main tendue qui
a été saisi au bond par audrey pulvar
qui elle en revanche je pense a besoin à
un moment donné d'un peu d'oxygène parce
que dans cette campagne des régionales
ça se passe pas très bien pour elle l
avait déjà fait ça elle a besoin d'aidé
la visibilité d'un aussi de montrer
qu'elle peut se replacer au centre du
jeu parce que d'une certaine manière la
invité par gérald darmanin et 1
éventuellement une rencontre phare a
beaucoup en parler ceci pourrait
volontaire de la part de gérald darmanin
selon vous non non je ne crois pas du
tout à ça parce que je vois pas très
bien l'intérêt pour gérald darmanin de
la soutenir dans cette période d'autant
que c'est bien les allées confiance ça
se passe on ne se passe en île de france
valable
valérie pécresse est très loin devant
audrey pulvar est dans les choux là ce
serait juste éventuellement lui donner
un jeu te dire un peu d'oxygène mais je
vois pas trop le goût et le jeu là
dedans darmanin joue un jeu un peu
personnel aussi de montrer un peu le
côté petit sarko aussi qui et
transgressif qui prend des décisions qui
est capable d'aller là où on l'attend
pas impulsif
un peu impulsif aussi parce que la
décision ou l'envi de porter plainte
l'annnonce de la plainte était peut-être
un peu aussi un coup de menton et là
coup il change un peu de pied aussi
vis-à-vis de quelqu'un comme votre et
pulvar qui est une femme et
pas très heureux ce genre de choses
aurore laluque comment à gauche on
perçoit cette séquence un peu un peu
lunaire faut le dire y compris pour nous
téléspectateurs et c'est plus que lui
nerveux je crois que ça dépasse même le
clivage gauche droite pour le coup c'est
à dire que et ça dépasse même audrey
pulvar c'est à dire que le sujet c'est
même pas audrey c'est le fait qu'on a
effectivement un mini ce qui fait une
espèce de coups de menton et qui nous
dit par twitter qui va porter plainte
est ce qu'il ya un fondement en
juridiquement possible à sa plainte
sincèrement je pense qu a pas de base
a priori non a priori non donc on voit
bien déjà que c'est déjà à la base nulle
et non avenue et que c'est du grand
n'importe quoi et par contre ça pose de
vrais soucis d'un point de vue
démocratique
ça pose un souci déjà passe codés
normalement il n'est censé garantir le
bon maintien des élections et il est en
train de s'adresser à une candidate
c'est un premier point
deuxième point tout le monde a le droit
de parler effectivement on est en
démocratie et nul ne doit être inquiété
pour son opinion ses opinions d'après
d'après la déclaration des droits de
l'homme nokia il ya un souci quand même
aussi à ce niveau là et puis enfin ces
espèces de 2 on tire le débat public
vers le bas en permanence qu'est ce
qu'on retient sur le fond de cette
séquence rayon qu'il soutient les
policiers peut-être mais si ça s'appelle
soutenir les policiers enfin excusez moi
elle les soutient pas bien ils portent
préjudice cela ils ne parleraient judith
qui ont un type qu'on soutient pas les
papilles c'est pas audrey pulvar contre
les policiers c'est pas l'assemblée
nationale et le parlement contre les
policiers
c'est quelqu'un qui a le droit de donner
son avis sur un rassemblement soutenu
par l'extrême mans et c est par ailleurs
est ce qu'on peut parler tranquillement
la police aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut
avoir un débat serein
qu'ils soient pas on est pour on est
content qu'ils aient compte la police
dans notre société
enfin je dire ce débat est complètement
absurde on a besoin d'une doctrine déjà
de maintien de l'ordre parce qu'elle a
été chamboulé certains ces dernières
années on avait une doctrine de matelas
qui étaient ils mettent en matière
d'éloignement on armer les policiers
d'une certaine façon qui fait que tout
est traîné saute
quelle est la nouvelle doctrine c'est ça
qui nous manque quelles sont les
formations
comment entrer pour maintenir la paix'
car il ya plein de sujets qui sont plus
des sujets vous
la démocratie qui font du bien et là on
est sur des choses ça excusez moi ça
tient pas la route
et d'ailleurs même au sein de la
majorité et ça crie ça crispe énormément
c'est à dire tout le monde mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ce truc et la joue et
là je vous rejoins parfaitement
il ajoute totalement perso c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on sent qu'il est dans une
stratégie très très personnelle
finalement et mais en tout cas ça fait
du mal au départ se fait du mal aux
débats bon faudrait quand même pas non
plus complètement inversé la charge de
la preuve quoi c'est pas darmana non
plus qu a fait du mal à la police la
rance et aussi quand même dans un moment
où la police aussi manifeste parce qu'il
y a eu des églises et des agressions
très graves contre les policiers
aujourd'hui les policiers genre menacés
ils pensent qu'ils ne peuvent plus faire
leur travail convenablement et il est ce
genre de déclarations
celle qui a fait audrey pulvar au nom de
cette manifestation était pour le moins
anachronique maladroite
ce n'était pas le bon moment quoi c'est
le terme c'est pas ce que je vais dire
mais quand on dit que le mec là sans ça
veut dire qu'il ya un effet de
sidération que c'est effroyable de voir
ce c'est cette manifestation de
solidarité aussi par rapport aux
victimes police de police hier c'était
un peu et puis ça venait de surcroît
après d'autres déclarations d'audrey
pulvar d'autres ont peu de dérapages son
histoire de rester dans l'arrondissement
tolérer accepte et s'est dit très réussi
non plus tout ça et elle est en campagne
mais bon c'est pas non plus le gérald
darmanin qui
ça a commis à mon avis une erreur
politique n'aurait pas dû porter plainte
on ne le fait pas pour toutes les
raisons évoquées je le partage
en revanche il a plutôt quand même voulu
montrer son soutien à chaque fois même
en allant dans la manif je suis pas sûr
que c'est dans son rôle de miss de
l'inter de manifester auprès des
policiers lui là pour gouverner et
éventuellement pour diriger à politis il
pas là pour manifester à ses côtés donc
tout ça et c'est dans l'ordre des choses
d'ailleurs cette manifestation puisse
passer place beauvau devant le devant
place beauvau aussi dire si elle les
policiers sont pas contents de la façon
et on peut comprendre
jeremiah il n'y a aucun sujet à ce
niveau là mais dans ce cas là pourquoi
devant l'assemblée nationale pourquoi
contre la justice alors que la justice
doit travailler
tout ça doit travailler en bonne
intelligence etc il ya classe et qu'il
faut respecter par ailleurs la
séparation des pouvoirs pourquoi fait
pourquoi tout ça que je suis aussi donc
c'est ça aussi des débats fut qui était
ouverture ban est absolument pas
concernant concernant audrey moi je ne
vois pulvar je ne vois strictement rien
de choquant dans ses propos dire que
quand elle voit l'extrême droite
soutenir certaines positions qu'elle ait
voix manifester devant l'assemblée
nationale que le ministre 6 juin contre
le ministre de la justice in fine et
devant la scène où s il ya un caractère
totalement totalement glaçant elle n'a
rien dit de choco à mon sens c'est sur
la question des réunions non mixtes bon
c'est vieux comme le monde
c'est vieux comme les années soixante
dix et des mouvements féministes et ça
ne choquait absolument absolument
personne d'autant que ce sont des
réunions qui sont sur la base du
volontariat et c sont pas des réunions
décisionnel et pour être une femme
je vous assure que des fois être entre
femmes pour pouvoir parler de certains
problèmes ça fait du bien alors on va
s'arrêter maintenant sur un autre sujet
un autre sujet très politique lui aussi
c'est l'interview d'emmanuel macron dans
le magazine zadig que vous avez lu
j'imagine un échange dans lequel le chef
de l'état nous livre sa vision
de la france son rapport au pays avant
de l'évoquer avec vous en plateau je
voudrais qu'on en parle avec le
fondateur et le directeur de la
publication eric fottorino bienvenue à
vous merci d'avoir accepté de participer
quelques minutes à ce match des idées
c'est un entretien finalement assez
original que vous avez menées là comment
vous le définiriez c'est un voyage un
peu spatio temporelle dans la france d'
emmanuel macron pourrait dire ça oui
c'est une longue conversation parce que
le préalable effectivement pour ce genre
d'entretien c'est le temps et vous vous
imaginez bien dans la république n'a pas
toujours beaucoup de temps et donc
j'avais insisté de mon côté pour avoir
deux heures d'entretien de conversation
libre sur sa vision de la france on lui
reproche souvent de d'avoir d'être un
peu hors sol de ne pas avoir de rapport
charnel avec notre pays
et j'avais envie d'aller le chercher
assez loin sur sur ses racines mais
aussi sur ces espèces de carte sensible
de la france d'un chef d'état qui dirige
ce pays depuis quatre ans qui a connu
les ces épisodes comme les gilet jaune
bien sûr la pandémie voilà donc c'est un
peu particulier effectivement comme
entretien il livre une analyse un peu
étonnante sur l'état du pays et sur le
peuple français je vous lis juste un
petit extrait parce que je laisserais
évidemment les spectateurs les
téléspectateurs acheter a dit mais je
vous le site
on revit des temps au fond très moyen
âgeux les grandes jacquerie les grandes
épidémies les grandes peurs c'est
l'époque des grandes peurs de phénomènes
qui forgent un peuple je dirais même la
réinvention d'une civilisation fin de
citation il a parfois eu des propos
d'historiens de sociologues non oui
c'est à dire que en fait à partir du
moment où on est dans une conversation
où on prend du recul on essaie de
comprendre ce pays
je lui ai effectivement je l' ai mis sur
cette voie lui demandons quel comment
pouvait-on relier ce qu'on vivait
aujourd'hui à ce qu'on a pu vivre dans
le passé et il a tout de suite balayée
d'un revers
main la libération 44 45 ans dix ans
quand tout est détruit il ya eu une
énergie vitale la cepalc a effectivement
il à rattacher la période convient à la
fin du moyen-âge mais il ajoute un peu
plus loin dans l'entretien et au début
de la renaissance c'est à dire que sa
conviction et je crois qu il y fort et
il y fonde aussi une partie de son
optimisme
c'est de dire oui les grandes jacquerie
et l'élégie les jaunes les grandes
pandémies on le voit avec le co vide
mais aussi les mutations technologiques
qui sont très anthropologique qui change
au sens où elle change la vie de tout un
chacun on le voit aujourd'hui le
télétravail comme la renaissance a été
l'imprimerie et beaucoup de d'innovation
ça aussi était aussi l'art je pense que
il voit là un parallèle sans le forcer
plus qu'il ne veut dire mais c'est
intéressant je trouve de de revenir à
cette période là l quelle impression
vous ressortez de cet entretien eric
fottorino parce que on peut dire c'est
quand même un entretien avec un
président en exercice candidat à sa
réélection
oui alors ce qui est intéressant c'est
que en fait on devait faire cet
entretien depuis longtemps depuis le
mois d'octobre
ça a été repoussée pour différentes
raisons que vous pouvez imaginer
et donc on arrive à aucun moment où
précisément on est à un an de la
présidentielle on est à la veille des
élections régionales ou quasiment
donc ça prend tout de suite une
dimension qu'il n'y avait pas
nécessairement dans notre conversation
mais à partir de là ce qui était je
trouve assez sensible dans ce que j'ai
perçu et c'était 7,7 volonté de montrer
d'un enracinement que c'est pas un homme
qui est seulement bien sûr d'amiens où
sa grand-mère dans les pyrénées et
parisiens mais c'est quelqu'un qui a
intégré beaucoup de choses de notre pays
même quelquefois violemment ou
difficilement avec les l'épreuve quoi
que le pays a vécu et c'est quelqu'un
qui aussi m'a paru très optimiste c'est
ça peut être bizarre de dire ça mais
j'ai bien senti
l'abattement houleux le poids du pouvoir
ou non il ya quelqu'un d'assez je trouve
léger au sens non pas
comment dire quelqu'un qui se préoccupe
pas de ce qui se passe pas du tout mais
léger au sens se garder quelque chose de
léger dans l'esprit pour avancer je suis
assez d'accord avec vous parce qu'on
sent d'ailleurs que il a l'impression
que les français vont rebondir et qu'ils
ont cette énergie pour y arriver on va
continuer à en parler si vous le voulez
bien avec nos invités en plateau et je
reviendrai vers vous dans un instant on
la lui quelle impression avec quelle
impression vous ressortez vous de cet
entretien
alors moi je m'en sors pas avec cette
impression là en fait j'avoue je voulais
en lisant cette interview je me suis
demandé s'il avait compris qu'il était
pressé dans la république et que ce
n'était pas une starlette voilà parce
que le les termes utilisés et je
comprends que ce soit l'exercice cette
interview c'est je sais moi c'est
enfants rois c'est mes moments de
bonheur c'est moi moi moi moi moi est en
fait y'a même pas un mot pour les
français on sort et un bon goût des
français depuis mais moi je ne vois pas
je ne vois je n'arrive pas à voir quels
lots maj finalement et quelle est la
perspective qu'il tire pour l'avenir
dans les français je ne vois pas les
réformes fondamentales à mettre en place
je ne vois pas comment on sort de la
crise sociale je dois pas comment sort
de la crise environnementale je dois pas
quand mon sens de la crise économique
donc je vois bien que je choque mais je
suis désolé moi je suis ressorti je suis
ressortie avec ça et par ailleurs je les
termes moyenâgeux etc
on sait qu'il aime les petites phrases
qui choque ce sont des phrases qui
choque à mon sens et qui font pas
forcément du bien qui peuvent être
d'ailleurs mal interprété parce que la
question du moyen âge est souvent manama
la namibie mode pays et même quand il
parle de la question par exemple des
corporatismes etc
il insiste beaucoup mais insiste
beaucoup là dessus moi je suis députée
européenne je suis coordinatrice de la
commission fiscalité
je dois faire face à des négociations où
la france a proposé à proposer dans un
trilogue donc commission il ya tout le
monde
une note qui a pris pour base le medef
une note écrite à la base par le medef
écrite par là bas tu parles aux manettes
sur la transparence fiscale des grandes
entreprises même si vous voulez quand
j'entends parler dans sap quand je vois
la question du corporatisme arrivée dans
cette interview
mais je me dis me se fout vraiment du
monde excusez moi donc en fait j'ai pas
je trouve qu'il n'arrive pas au bon
moment cette interview c'est à dire qui
à la rigueur
si on est dans quelque chose d'intimiste
etc autant vraiment attendre la fin de
la crise autant que les grandes réformes
qui devraient être mises en place soit
mise en place et que ça aille mieux pour
pouvoir avoir cette interview là pour
moi ce que je dois vous avouer que après
la séquence en plus un mc fly cailleteau
je suis je suis assez choqué parce que
par exemple en tant que députée
européenne j'aimerais avoir des laptops
répond sur la fiscalité
ça fait deux mois qu'on leur demande
faut voir la honte qu'on se tape au
parlement bien et non à la constitution
européenne je vais vous laisser répondre
eric fottorino et je vous donne la
parole juste après ils devraient oui
mais c'est toujours intéressant de voir
comment un entretien peut être un moment
donné commenté et puis perçu c'est
egypte qui dix ans c'est ce qu'on a dit
on ne sait pas tout ce qu'on a dit alors
il ya il ya peut-être entre les lignes
des des choses à apercevoir que moi je
n'ai pas perçu dans l'entretien en
revanche là où je pense factuellement
que vous avez tort c'est que je crois
que c'est précisément un entretien où il
parle que des français et donc si vous
voulez peut-être qu'ils en parlent pas
bien ou pas comme vous aimeriez
longtemps mais en tout cas ce qu'il dit
lui sur sa sur son parcours personnel
c'est de dire qu'il est fils de cheminot
que ses grands-parents habitent près
d'une nationale que ses cousins ont
commencé à connaître le chômage à un
moment donné avec la
désindustrialisation et il parle de la
morsure de la désindustrialisation et en
disant notamment que on a on s'est
trompé et lui le premier en pensant
qu'on pouvait bâtir un pays sans
industrie
donc si vous voulez je n'ai pas le
sentiment qu'ils ne parlent pas des
français après j'ai l'impression que
c'est vous qui faites des formules de
starlettes et serra je vois pas du tout
ça je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui se
livre mais qui est quand même en phase
avec ce que doit être un président c'est
à dire regardez le pays
non pas que au fond des yeux comme dit
alice car autrefois mais il le regarde
avec des cartes il regardait de
l'histoire il regardait de la sociologie
et ce qu'ils disent sur marseille ou sur
figeac s'est pas c'est pas un jeu c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui a été je pense au
contact quelquefois brutalement ça la
réalité lui est arrivé brutalement dans
la figure et c'est plus ça que j'ai
j'ai senti juste juste pour revenir là
dessus et tu devrais bien sûr excusez
moi c'est juste
il la voit à travers sa famille en fait
moi c'est ça qui me pose un problème
c'est à travers lui lui lui oui au tabac
et je le vois pas au service pour le
coup je suis désolé le voir c'est
certain a visité le service d'intérêt
général après cette heure au temps perdu
et je ferai moi je la vois pas du tout
comme ça c'est interview parce que
j'avoue que j'ai trouvé que cet
entretien était extrêmement intéressant
il y a une dimension intellectuelle chez
emmanuel macron qui n'a peut-être pas si
souvent l'occasion de s'exprimer et d'un
site cet entretien je trouve qu'elle
s'exprime on voit on peut imaginer qu'il
a été secrétaire particulier de paul
ricoeur et qu'il eu des échanges un peu
philosophique et de haut niveau pendant
quelques années avec fabrika donc là je
vois pas en fait tant que ça de nos
anciens présidents capable de mener un
entretien de cette manière là est de
porter ce regard sur la france avec
cette dimension historique sociologique
géographique qui l'a amené alors après
je trouve au contraire que c'est une
mais tout le contraire c'est une
interview extrêmement inclusive et moi
c'est ça qui m'a plu ce qu'il dit sur
les migrants africains dans lesquels il
voit l'avenir de la france il le dit
dans l'entretien
c'est extrêmement fort la manière des
femmes vous qui êtes là par les cruautés
de l'histoire par la volonté de vos
grands parents de vos parents ou par là
votre propre vous est une chance pour
notre pays
quel président
a dit cela oser aux migrants africains
qui vivent en france et ceux qui sont
devenus français d'ailleurs même et
qu'on regarde aujourd'hui de travers et
qu'on montre du doigt un jeu voilà donc
là on est en campagne je suis pas sûr
qu'il parle à des gens qui votent
énormément d'ailleurs quand il parle de
la seine saint denis il n'a pas
peut-être beaucoup d'électeurs en
seine-saint-denis mais quand il la
présente comme la future californie en
france va et dimanche la mère céline
lemaire oui mais c'est vrai qu'il ya il
il essaye aussi de mettre de l'énergie
là où elle doit être mise parce que il
ne nie pas d'ailleurs dans l'entretien
les problèmes qu'il peut y avoir
les fragilités du pays des fragilités de
la région qui se lèveront seine saint
denis mais il ya aussi une énergie
formidable des entreprises qui se créent
tous les jours plus que n'importe où
ailleurs le stade de france c'est donc
il va aussi sur des terrains où on ne
l'attendait pas et après qu'il ait voulu
montrer à travers cet entretien qu'il
n'est pas que le président de la start
up nation très ancré à paris et des
réseaux parisiens aidé la banque
rothschild ça c'est bien possible
pourquoi pas après tout parce qu'il ya
d'autres dimensions chez ce personnage
qui cherche emmanuel macron qui
apparaissent fortement dans cet
entretien et puis enfin sur la séquence
je crois que là pour le coup il ya quand
même plutôt une intelligence de
communication il a fait mach laïque et
carlito il a parlé aux jeunes et il a
dix ont un petit peu fait dans la
légèreté ce week end
cette fois ci il va plutôt dans la
profondeur et de ses idées et je vois
bien que il est possible que la séquence
était aient pensé d'ailleurs de manière
globale par la cellule communication du
goût de l'elysée
mais il parle il parle et moi j'ai
trouvé sarrance j'ai pas trouvé qui
arrive je le trouve ça con france j'ai
trouvé sa santé la naphtaline
j'ai trouvé ça vieux j'ai pas trouvé
qu'à être vision d'avenir elle est où la
vision pour le pays elles sont où les
réformes même chose avec mac faye
carlito il parle il parle il parle
oui dans un entretien au pardon
tant qu'à faire une proposition non mais
on proposait riffard je crois pas qu'il
voit eric fottorino pourra peut-être
vous répondre et je ne crois pas qu'il a
voulu faire une interview programmatique
pour 2022 ou lui demander son interview
bilan sa politique de droite l'idée
était par ailleurs et avec les siens
un travail introspectif de demander le
regard de ma tronche sur la france peut
être aussi de mieux comprendre le
président et je trouve qu'on comprend
mieux l'homme on n'est pas toujours
obligé d'être dans la politique de
l'instant et de faire l'entretien du
figaro libé c'est s'aider autre chose et
moi j'ai apprécié et écouté quand on
fait une analyse on dit qu'un problème
de désindustrialisation quand on parle
de figeac et quand on parle du problème
des services publics etc etc
c'est pas comme si les pas des gens qui
se mobilisent est depuis des années en
france notamment depuis le début le
début du mandat des manuels mâcon pour
dire qu'il ya un problème dans les
services publics ya un problème dans les
hôpitaux il ya un problème dans
l'éducation nationale et qu'on est en
train de perdre de l'industrie
énormément par rapport à d'autres pays
comparativement par exemple un pays
comme l'italie
donc une fois qu'on a dit ça c'est super
très bien un président de la république
fait une analyse comme ça moi je suis
désolé même en tant que citoyenne même
pas en tant qu'élu j'ai envie de dire
qu'est ce que vous proposez
je suis désolé j'attends pas d'un
président d'un public qui me fasse une
fantastique analyse sociologique ou
encore hot évite à réaliser etc
j'attends qu'ils me montrent des
perspectives notamment dans un moment on
a une crise économique terrible une
crise sociale terrible est que la france
n'était pas déjà dans un bel état avant
avant la crise en jeu donc je suis
désolé je vois pas pourquoi on serait en
train de s'extasier devant une analyse
il est président de la république est
réparé eric fottorino la lettre un
analyste un dernier mot pour conclure
sur cette partie oui je pense qu'elle
est intéressant au fait à travers ce qui
ce qui est dit sélection la temporalité
de la gestion du temps indique ça nous a
pas échappé est un trimestriel
donc vous imaginez que un trimestriel
c'est pas comme un quotidien je connais
bien les quotidiens où on peut être très
réactif et surtout interroger une
personnalité sur des questions
d'actualité
là on n'était pas dans ce dance a donc
effectivement ce que dit monsieur de ré
c'est exactement là j'allais dire le
l'état d'esprit qui m'a conduit à
l'interroger c'était de nous sortir de
l'actualité et d'avoir une analyse
structurée de son regard après les
filets jaunes et avec la pandémie
donc si vous voulez c'était pas le lieu
je trouve de 10 d'annoncer des réformes
ou de dire on va faire ça pour les
impôts faire ça pour les territoires
s'était déjà d'avoir une vision claire
le plus clair possible de la réalité et
française et je pense que de ce point de
vue là le contrat est rempli
un tout dernier - yves derai alors je
crois juste que là dans l'allée
divergences qu'on peut avoir par rapport
à ces entretiens
vous avez simplement le regard là d'une
adversaire politique d' emmanuel macron
qui est en charge elle-même qui est élu
et puis moi je suis journaliste et c'est
vrai que je j'apprécie le travail qui a
été fait aussi et la manière dont cet
entretien était conduit donc voilà je
crois que c'est aussi ça qui fait qu'on
n'a pas tout à fait la même
mais merci eric fottorino d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir merci d'avoir
accueilli favorablement même des
critiques sur cette interview merci
beaucoup
on avance un petit peu dans ce match il
nous reste quelques minutes on va
reparler des élections régionales pour
revenir sur le dernier sondage
enfin l'un des derniers il y en a
beaucoup celui d'harris interactive pour
ce qui est des autres france on a un
casier bertreau qui semble confirmer son
avance il va tout droit vers un deuxième
mandat 35% des intentions de vote a
priori la liste du rassemblement
national 30% la gauche unifiée qui
obtiendrait 19 % des voix et la
république en marche qui plafonne donc a
priori à 11%
ce qui semble montrer l'effet très
limité de l'arrivée d'un eric
dupond-moretti dre ça ça semble
maintenant photons un petit peu parce
que l'arrivée nouvelle le sondage est là
la campagne les moments de la campagne
avant d'arriver donc on verra mais je ne
fallait pas peut-être pas non plus
s'attendre à des miracles d'eric
dupond-moretti qui est d'abord n'a pas
beaucoup d'expérience politique qui a
commis je pense quelques maladresses
dans certaines attaques contre leurs
accents martiaux nal qui sont un peu
datées on sait qu'elle marche pas cette
diabolisation un peu premiers devraient
elles fonctionnent pas depuis longtemps
il faut ce n'est déjà plus depuis jean
marie le pen donc encore moins face à
marine le pen qui ne donne plus beaucoup
de prises à cette diabolisation elle
fait tout pour vraiment être dans les
clous un peu sur la plupart des sujets
même si elle continue à défendre un
programme vision de la france pour le
coup là qui n'est pas la même que celle
dont on entend parler avec emmanuel
macron il ne dirait pas bienvenue et
merci à l'émigration africaine et bravo
la seine-saint-denis sur donc voilà donc
moi je m'attendais pas à révolutionner
chose après je suis je pense que vous
allez peut-être un peu vite quand on
annonce d'ores et déjà la victoire de
xavier bertrand à partir de cette
enquête on n'est quand même pas très
loin de la marge d'erreur quand il ya
cinq points entre lui et le rn il faut
quand même faire attention il ya des
candidats qui sont assez loin derrière
mais il ya là une campagne qui arrive
je ne sais pas si tout est joué prudence
prudence aux aurores laluque cette
gauche unifiée environ à 19% des voix
vous êtes satisfaite vous vous dites que
ça marche la gauche de ne pas être
satisfait de l'état de la gauche dans le
pays dont la suivre autour de ce chiffre
la danse après effectivement on est sur
des sondages ban on aimerait bien que ce
soit ce soit bien mieux évidemment mais
évidemment après il ya tout à faire
il ya tout à faire et là on peut prendre
le cas des eaux france mais sur
l'ensemble du pays il ya une bataille
culturelle a gagné déjà ça commence par
ça et puis après ils votent une bataille
culturelle
bah c'est à dire qu'on voit très bien la
façon dont ces dernières années il ya eu
une
il ya eu une bataille culturelle qui a
fait que le néolibéralisme quelque part
a gagné il ya plein d'éléments de
langage d'un point de vue économique qui
sont passées comme ça comme une espèce
de faits stylisés comme l'espèce de
vérité il ya trop d'impôts en france
il ya trop de fonctionnaires il faut
absolument son prix mais on pouvait pas
parler de la dette sans dire qu'il
fallait à l'époque avant crise sans dire
que le pays était gravement endettée
tout ça c'était c'était des contre
vérités absolues
voilà mais petit à petit ça fonctionne
et ça m'a mis là nous en avions contre
balancer avec d'autres éléments de
langage lui dire autre chose pourquoi il
n'a pas pris mais je pense qu'à un
moment dans ma vision des choses je me
trompe peut-être mais j'ai l'impression
que face à cette espèce de contre
révolution néolibérale qui a commencé et
qui a été très brutal il faut se
rappeler qu'on est dans les années 20 70
on est dans le keynésianisme et puis
tout d'un coup margaret thatcher reagan
arrivé au pouvoir les think tanks ont
travaillé bien à l'as vence pour
proposer des mesures néolibérales parce
qu'elles ne sont pas libéral j'insiste
là dessus et tout se retourne très
rapidement et on ouvre on entre dans une
nouvelle ère libéralisation de la
finance privatisations etc etc
donc ça a été j'ai l'impression que la
gauche s'est retrouvée là dedans un peu
en inertie quelques parfums
non plutôt prise un peu comme comme un
animal dans les phares d'une voiture
elle a été un peu tétanisé disons face à
des éléments de langage qui faisait chic
et moderne qui faisait sérieux qu'ils
aient sérieux voilà
et alors qu'en économie penser que ça
fonctionne pas ça fonctionne pas du tout
comme ça donc là aujourd'hui on est en
train de revenir
ir là dessus parce qu'on se rend compte
aussi que balla la misère sociale ça a
des conséquences démocratique et je
pense que les américains ont eu de
grosses frayeurs avec le capitole à ce
niveau là on est en train de s'en rendre
compte
tout court avec trump est allé en tout
pour avec trappe déjà avant tout à fait
on voit on voit très bien que quand il
n'y a pas d'éducation quand il ya du
désespoir bah oui ça donne certaines
choses d'un point de vue politique donc
ça agite et on voit qu'il ya un retour
des grandes institutions internationales
qui était avant très néo libérale la
banque mondiale ocde les fmi qui sont en
train de changer totalement leur
discours sur les inégalités en disant il
ya trop d'inégalités il n'y a pas assez
d'investissements publics
il faut revenir sur les questions
fiscales et c'est donc maintenant à nous
porter ses idées et vous allez être
fruste rive mais on n'avait plus le
temps de répondre merci en tout cas
merci à tous les bus mais en participer
ce match d arriver en fin de cette
émission on se retrouve demain à 18
heures pour un nouveau numéro de
dialogue citoyen va s'interroger
justement sur la perte de confiance dans
la démocratie on va écouter des français
et des françaises déçu parfois même
écoeuré mais certains ont décidé quand
même d'avancer de faire de la politique
autrement donc on les entendra et ils
échangeront évidemment avec les élus de
la haute assemblée demain également
bonjour chez vous cette heure et demie
au rayonnement de chimie recevra
notamment ian brossât porte parole du
parti communiste je vous souhaite une
excellente soirée sur xla
[Musique]
oh